hey everyone and welcome back to
Westeros weekly I'm Liana Galera I'm a
Strawson and I believe we had one of the
best episodes of Game of Thrones ever it
would be sure to step aside all time but
I'm going to say it's the best episode
of all time and say so I mean we really
saw those dressings in action and hope
we had so much to discuss today plus we
had an exclusive wildfire Fast Five with
Game of Thrones super fan deck Shepard
apart a little early in the show but
it's way too early for this are you
getting this call yeah
we're getting it I'm sorry we're doing a
start sister off your sister update
[Music]
actually have a star sister I'll save
this we haven't you guys we didn't think
he was going to happen this early on no
I actually our predictions are wrong we
really thought that aria was going to
maybe not go back to Winterfell but
she's going to note back there and
continue with her plan to go kill Cersei
yeah and then ax Sansa and Arya reunited
in that crib it was a little dark what
did you think about having their first
reunion be right in front of there in
front of that yeah I had Statue who we
loved that I mean they haven't seen each
other and so long and so much has
changed between them and the way they
act and the way they appear and yeah I
thought it was really appropriate I
loved
Arya's first lines to Sansa does that
mean I have to call you lady stark now
so perfect but I loved their interaction
as soon as they got there hugged out of
their way and this is what they said how
did she go back to Winterfell I'm sorry
I imagine you're just too
yes
most very pleasant one mine either
but all stories on either yet no not
over yet there no I made a check away
though is that sophie Turner is a liar
she's a really good liar lied to us at
Comic Con and I really believed her I
said that was the thing so we caught up
with sophie Turner we told her about the
struck sister update as you remember a
couple episodes episodes ago and this is
what she said it was really funny I mean
it would be amazing if they were to
cross over at some point but I think we
have more chance in the Marvel Universe
witness in Game of Thrones it's a lot
about happy endings on Game of Thrones
look I guess what they lie and they try
self but that was like that was my good
one that got me a little bit that was
been really good especially because she
created another alibi like Oh could
happen in this franchise I don't know
I'm just so like pumped in a happy in
general and then also they're like well
brands here but he's a little weird now
not the same as you remember or not the
same but it was how nice to see great
start walking into Winterfell together
like it was so crazy we haven't seen
that many Starks together soon season 1
yeah and and so much has changed I mean
Sansa is like deserving of the throne at
this point hotcake yeah I said it Arya's
a bit of a murder and like a murder that
we're rooting for and the brands like
have been brands like uh yeah he really
did he died back in that cave and that
was such an interesting scene where he
was just like thanks bye see ya cold
cold blooded cold maybe ICS moment of
the night we're not doing I want to fig
yeah oh speaking of Arya we got to talk
about the face-off between our en
Brienne this was a showdown that I
didn't know that I wanted but now I need
every single week I was like white
knuckle in my couch but also it was
really interesting watching Sansa watch
that because originally when I was
watching the scene of her watching them
I thought that maybe she was upset that
Brianna was like getting closer with her
but then I realized that she's just
processing like what happened to my
little sister when did she become this
little assassin right yeah oh so good is
she here right a scene I didn't know I
do
it but now I need much more of it so
much more and there was so much more
that happened in this night's episode so
let's take it to the Nights Watch John
and Seon little Aki another reunion but
I was completely not expecting now what
when you finally realize that Theon was
coming up on that boat and that he and
John were going to see each other what
did you think was going to happen I
didn't know how he was going to react
because obviously you know fian did save
smiles right yeah - Sansa seems to be on
his side and I thought ok it's going to
be it's gonna be right maybe the hugs
yeah no not exactly because the thing is
we have been thinking about Seon so much
as a beaten-down guy as reek as someone
who's been tormented by Ramsay Bolton
for so long but we forgot that or I
forgot that a couple seasons ago Yun was
a huge bleep yeah he was he wonderful
I mean awful much much of Westeros
believed that he killed Brandon Rica
exactly and also she's completely
betrayed robb stark and he is in my
opinion part of the reason why rob was
killed yes yes so I was kind of glad
that I'm really enjoying seeing Jon get
really up in people's faces and being
like if you hurt someone I will kill you
I love it I love how protective he is
like his women in his life Korean if you
were to get like that with Miss Danny
huh bring them to the next point John
and Danny okay so John brought Danny
into those caves in Dragonstone to show
him all of the different dragon glass
and he's going to be mining as weapons
and we've got a little bit of a surprise
yeah are you talking about the paintings
or the carvings of a sexual tension I
was going to talk about the sexual times
okay I knew that you would get it yeah
because they're you know they're
standing in such close proximity now you
know we all felt this chemistry but then
in the inside the episode afterwards
with the executive producers they were
like yeah you were meant to feel that
they're starting to build an attraction
towards each other and I love that
they're really Oh spoken words about it
it was all just from their chemistry
yeah and they do have it do you think
that Rose Leslie is watching with Kit
Harington on a couch at home just being
like hmm a lot of sparks flying oh yeah
she is a girlfriend of mine I have to
watch them engaged in that scenes with
other people weird
but I really did love interaction that
Danny and John had where they were like
trying to like convince one another and
then Danny said this amazing line I will
fight you I will fight for him when he
bend the knee do I think that he's going
to bend the knee for Danny
yes but here's also what I think Danny
and John are going to get married
because there's nothing better than an
alliance through marriage yeah to make
everyone okay
Oh a nice aunt and nephew marriage we're
not talking about that part right now
that's just a fact
Game of Thrones super fan deck Shepherd
we all do exact same way that we do and
if you guys don't know Dec Sheppard and
his adorable wife Kristen Bell are
probably the biggest Game of Thrones
fans out there they have dressed up as
cool ECN Khal Drogo for Halloween before
they have gone to all the Game of
Thrones premiers the even redid the game
of Thrones opening sequence with their
own interpretation playing the
instruments
[Music]
relationship Gold relationship goal and
this is what Dax told us about his
thoughts on Dani and John getting
together my sole obsession is how soon
after John Snow and Khaleesi meet will
they kiss and get horizontal that's
almost all I care about at this point
for season seven I feel like that's
there's sexual tension that's been
burbling for years even though they've
never even seen them together I can feel
the tension is palpable
I trust the guy in over also yeah so
well and just to let you guys know we
actually caught up with Dax while he was
filming a very super-secret Funny or Die
skit so we can't tell you anything about
that but that's what the overall there'd
be overall so horribly about where maybe
you were them I don't know I hate I I
don't know about that but I do know this
time for keeping up with Khaleesi here
is so much more to talk about when it
comes to Danny especially the left the
loot train battle Wow is this the best
battle in Game of Thrones history that's
because bit for one of the very first
times we didn't necessarily know who to
root for I think that that's a very good
point I think that was one where and I
kept saying it out loud I was like I
don't want anything definite bran I want
to be top of Jamie along I think that's
Danny I don't want to think that mad
rogue on I didn't know what I didn't
know whose side I was on and it was so
interesting to watching Tyrion watch
this battle because you we felt like we
were watching it kind of through his
eyes if you watch my brother and he's
watching his Queen and but okay did you
get chills when Danny came on wood drove
on and then said her iconic line yes
let's take a look I start screaming
[Music]
most poor Lannister didn't see the chief
it just so show never stops surprising
me because I always think I'm like okay
I can watch this I watch this I get we
do an after show I always get one step
ahead of the show no no I am no Cersei
no but here was the ultimate surprise
the fact that on their little journeys
back to King's Landing
they brought a secret weapon with them
yeah they're the square became friends
talking with them I was not expecting
that I was sitting there thinking I was
like okay well obviously Danny is going
to take them all out because they don't
have the scorpion it spits down in the
and the jungeum underneath King's
Landing no and then all honestly that
thing's pretty easy to operate to
because bronze Roger Ascham that's it
out I got it he didn't need any
instructions or anything but oh right
there know the sound that Drago I'm
really nervous here yeah I got so
nervous I originally thought that it was
going to go straight through his mouth
yeah and I also stopped breathing for
like 20 minutes
but I think I got really nervous because
I saw a tweet where somebody was like no
before I watched it and I was like who
and then I closed down Twitter but I
thought maybe Danny was going else we've
got me really I was really nervous and
like also amazing really scared to fly
again because like she had like extreme
turbulence yeah I just landed off okay
but how is not the most shocking moment
no yet to even get to it the fact that
Jamie saw his opportunities after droven
got hurt Danny is trying to pull the
scorpion spear out of them yep and James
like this is my chance so he grabs a
spear and he goes right on over and this
is what happened
[Music]
James for me is like the ultimate
redemption character because I'm like
waiting for him kind of not in this
instance but he realized gotta go after
her while she has her back turned like a
coward carry on yeah we've gone from
that I guess if that's your only
opportunity you seize it and it's not
necessarily that her back has turned
it's that she just burned up his entire
army but here's my question for you do
you think that was Braun who saved Jamie
I think I don't know who else it
would've been hoovered dick on oh man
I'm surprised my dick on he where did
that's a hot hard frost come from I
don't know anyway insert sexual joke
here but basically I think it was Braun
because when we saw that he was down he
saw an unmanned white horse just kind of
run by and that's the horse that jumped
over the only thing is that I don't
think the horse is survived I'm sorry I
found amazing as this episode was
whenever they were actually like herding
the horses and then one of the Dothraki
cut the leg off of the horse I got so
upset last night I found it really
really uncomfortable to watch yeah I
agree I started screaming yeah I should
have crying haha but honestly last
night's episode was insane yeah there
were so many new moments but there are
also so many callbacks to old moments
which brings us to the north to
remembers and this week we're talking
all about the jagger
which kind of became a weird like main
character of the episode pretty much
very important it's definitely going to
become like the most important i think
that this is going to be a dagger that's
going to kill someone very important so
it's the cat's paw dagger it's made of
Valyrian steel which we know can kill
white Walker I'm going to be very
helpful yeah moving forward and it's now
an REO secession but it's important
because it was used to attempt to kill
brand in season one by a mysterious
hired assess exactly let's take a look
back at that way rewind moment you're
not supposed to be here no one's
supposed to be
it's Amasa he's dead already
no I mean that was the dagger that whole
scene kind of essentially ignited the
war between the Lannisters and the start
exactly and we know that brands okay
because his direwolf saved him his tire
wolf looks very nice
not these guys very nice not these was
desirable uh but so whose dagger is it I
think it's a little finger I think it's
little fingers because he admitted to
Ned he's like oh yeah that's my dagger
but you know I actually lost it Tyrion
Lannister but we know that he's all
about manipulating situations for his
gain I really think that it was him all
along and that was igniting the war
between the Lannisters in the start
right and then he says the whole chaos
is a ladder line and it's I mean that
ran through vakidis face well I was like
I know what you're doing yes honestly I
cannot wait okay I'm not sure how I feel
about a creepy like emotionally
emotionless brand right now but I really
want him to just really confront
Littlefinger and be like I see all I
know all your awful yeah it seemed like
he's kind of not quite found his footing
with what he's supposed to do yet but he
kind of figures it out of vines his
purpose oh he's going to shine he is
going to shine it's gonna shine how he's
shine the spotlight on Dax Shepard right
now yes I love those overalls let's
bring them back yeah it's time for our
walls are fast by with Jack Shepard
ah the hounds
I love characters who you think you hate
and then slowly fall in love with them
and he checked that box for me Ned Stark
seriously yeah I don't know how unlikely
it is but obviously I was the duo I'm
hoping comes together is Scalisi and Jon
Snow again I just want to see the two
most attractive people unwanted I think
Khaleesi is going to be on the Iron
Throne because she's the mother of
dragons
I love the his most devoted Denarius and
ever team Danny fan like Simone like
most of us I think exactly I think we
should probably check out who was in the
lead on our little race me to the iron
throne to the iron throne
alright so right now we've got Cersei up
on front obviously she's pulled some
stuff she really had and also Danny if
you'll recall last week was way in last
place because she lost so many for
allies but she really turned it around
this week she took Lady Olenna advice
and she's like sorry Tyrion I'm no
longer listening to you I'm there just
be a super amazing dragon leader I'm
gonna be a drag I'm gonna be a dragon
and then we've got Jon Snow in the back
because he doesn't even look around he's
like focused on other sunshine but like
also he's still in the game somehow it's
not he's winning the show because he's
focused on the true battle ahead
absolutely which is humanity versus the
White Walkers and he's down there he's
busy mining his dragonglass he's ready
he's discovered some cave drawings like
he's just having a grand old time I
don't need to listen to John I really
need to listen to John I think it's time
for so listen flash watch the teaser for
next next and we can discuss everything
that happened let's take a look I'm not
here to murder bend the knee and join me
or refuse and die
you need to find a way to make a listen
whatever stands in our way
[Music]
run for the night king and his army
marching towards East watcher above
things are coming
bad things are coming do you think when
Danny is saying bend the knee do you
think Jamie is standing now I kiss your
hook I didn't think about that do you
think he maybe I hope that he's alive I
don't he's a lot of well she wouldn't
just yes no he's alive
he left he was just a little knocked out
he's a little scared he had a dragon
right in his face he went underwater
he's alive but we need to talk about the
fact that Danny's giving me some serious
Mad King vibes Ingvild
badly I'm lovin it though and also when
Vera sustained to Tyrion you need to
find a way to make her listen to you
again I think she's totally just like no
well because also Tyrion thinks like a
Lannister and Cersei thinks like a
Lannister so everything that Tyrion is
doing
Cersei can predict and and it's not it's
not good for Dany she need someone that
thinks differently than a Lannister I
never thought of it like that I was
thinking that you know he's one of the
most intelligent characters on the show
he came up with all these clever plans
but I really liked that he was trying to
avoid all these casualties and but now
Danny's just like we can't do that
anymore they keep killing our people so
why can't we kill their right I mean I
loved hearing I keep him around I'll get
around them please don't get rid of but
I don't think she should be and she
should be taking his advice as closely
as she had been here's what I'm worried
about
it's been a while since we've had a
pretty significant death I think next
week is when it's going to happen and we
had thought that it was going to be
great warm he's okay he's okay
but I was only worried we were going to
lose bran in tonight's episode but he's
okay I really think that next week in
the battle for the White Walkers because
it's looking like it's gonna be the
White Walkers in the wildlings okay I
don't want to say I don't want you to
say it I'm really I don't want you to
say I'm really worried I don't want you
to or mom can you point to the guys
talking I know they can think they need
to have their own Sunday a grey worm
moment and Karma's not ready he hasn't
found love he's not ready I think that
okay and if it's not
Terron I really do think that someone
next week is gonna die because oh my
gosh Ashley are you guys know uh it is
we only have three episodes left yeah
season nine episodes left in total how
crazy is that
who's gonna bite it who's gonna bite it
make your prediction now besides two a
month
I wanna make a bold one okay I'm going
Tyrion no it's just I don't it who else
who could it be huh I don't want it to
be wrong but I'm just trying to
eliminate I feel like they got to tell
somebody major instead of somebody
that's like okay that's luck well and I
would say Jaime but I think that Jamie's
going to be the one that kills Cersei
so mmm-hmm so many things let us know
here is going to kill Cersei so maybe
not Tyrion oh I don't know why don't
know what you guys think he'll if your
theories in the comments below because
we are dying to know and we will
incorporate them into next week's
episode yeah we will read them thank you
so much for tuning in to this week's
episode of Westeros week we really
appreciate it like subscribe comment
tweet a Twitter yeah we'll see you next
week
bye guys